l'hôpital dans la rue forte mobilisation
des personnels aujourd'hui à paris ils
étaient entre 6 et 15 mille selon les
sources pour demander plus de créations
d'emplois à l'occasion du passage aux 35
heures
quelques incidents en fin de
manifestation ce fait divers qui
provoque une émotion particulière à
evreux un père de famille venu
s'expliquer avec les racketteurs de son
fils a été battu à mort à coups de
briques deux de ses agresseurs ont été
arrêtés
l'espoir aura été de courte durée au
proche orient 39 morts aujourd'hui côté
palestinien la ville de ramallah est
entièrement occupée à sept israéliens
dont cinq civils ont été tués par
ailleurs dans un attentat près de la
frontière libanaise au nord du pays
comment maîtriser l'immigration venus
des pays de l'est et notamment de la
roumanie
l'enquète de cette édition sur les
filières de bucarest à l'aide notamment
de faux documents enfin la mode la
continuité pour le premier défilé yves
saint laurent après le retrait du m a
toujours beaucoup de noir est toujours
très féminin bonsoir à tous merci de
votre attention avant de développer ses
titres cette nouvelle affaire qui
concerne la transfusion sanguine
un cas de contamination par le virus du
sida a été décelée c'est le premier
depuis quatre ans il s'agit d'une femme
de 80 ans environ décédés depuis mais
pour d'autres raisons c'est bernard
kouchner lui-même qui l'a révélé il ne
s'agit pas d'une erreur de dépistage
tout système a ses limites
il n'y a pas de garantie complète a
précisé le ministre explication josé
blanc lapierre alexandre de laval une
personne contaminée par le virus du sida
à la suite d'une transfusion sanguine
l'accident ne s'était pas produit depuis
quatre ans la preuve que le risque zéro
n'existe pas on n'a pas inventé
le meilleur sécurité elle n'est pas
parfaite
il reste quelques petits pourcentages
très très faible mais qui demain 2
d'être contaminés sans qu'on sache avec
ce nouveau cas de contamination c'est le
problème du don du sang qui est posée en
effet un volontaire pour donner son sang
toute bonne foi sans savoir qu'il a
contracté le virus
car un délai nécessaire avant de pouvoir
dépister l'infection on a mis en place
un nouveau test qui permet de détecter
de façon beaucoup plus précoce
auparavant c'était de l'ordre de 20 à 25
jours maintenant on arrive à détecter la
présence lui même du virus moins de huit
jours après la date de la contamination
donc ça c'est un élément qui vient
renforcer la sécurité sanitaire des
produits sanguins
aujourd'hui le risque d'être contaminées
lors d'une transfusion sanguine et de 1
cas pour trois millions et demi de
donneurs et pour encore limiter le
risque les donneurs de sang sont
soumises à un questionnaire qui permet
d'éliminer d'emblée 20% des volontaires
on reste dans le domaine de la santé
avec cette nouvelle mobilisation des
personnels hospitaliers manifestation
nationale à paris
ils étaient quinze mille selon les
organisateurs 6000 selon la police
quatre syndicats contestent toujours
vous le savez le protocole guigou sur
les 35 heures qui prévoit la création de
45 mille emplois sur trois ans martin
gouès jacques gérard olivier robert ils
veulent pas trop reçu par le ministre de
la santé
mais ils sont attendus
policiers et manifestants se sont
affrontés au pied du bureau de bernard
kouchner
les hospitaliers venait demander de
nouvelles négociations sur les 35 heures
nous ce qu'on demande s'était pas
supplémentaire on peut pas passer à 35
heures supplémentaires ils sont venus de
toute la france de bretagne comme des
bouches du rhône le défilé était alors
bon enfant jusqu'au retour d'une
délégation
elle vient de rencontrer un
collaborateur d'elisabeth guigou
déçus les manifestants se dirigeront
vers les bureaux de bernard kouchner à
300 mètres de là entre les ministres et
les agents hospitaliers
le torchon continue de brûler foyer à ce
jour les deux tiers des hôpitaux ont
signé un accord sur le temps de travail
accord qui prévoit selon les cas entre 6
et 20 jours de congés supplémentaires
par an autre manifestation à paris celle
des gardiens de prison là encore à
propos de l'application des 35 heures
ils étaient un millier dans la rue
amélioration en revanche du côté des
chauffeurs routiers avec la levée
progressive des barrages ici à lagrasse
in hier près de nantes
trois des quatre syndicats ont appelé à
la fin du mouvement en raison notamment
des consignes de suspension de permis de
conduire données aux préfets six points
de blocages étaient recensés en fin
d'après midi contre 22 hier 6 points
tous dans le midi nous allons à evreux
maintenant je vous le disais un père de
famille venu défendre son fils victime
d'une tentative de racket a été battu à
mort par les agresseurs cela s'est passé
ce week-end les on ne l'apprend
qu'aujourd'hui un peu avant la mère du
jeune homme s'était rendu au
commissariat pour porter plainte les
policiers avaient justifié l'absence
d'intervention par le manque d'effectifs
paul de genève alexis fisher sur place
vendredi en fin d'après-midi la gare
routière d'evreux répondait des
centaines de lycéens se retrouvent ici
guy patrice bergues et là aussi la
veille son fils s'est fait racketter en
rentrant chez lui le père de famille
veut s'expliquer avec les agresseurs
mais quand ils les trouvent la situation
dégénère il reçoit une brique en plein
visage
cada flora puisqu'un dégueulasse c'est
qu'il s'acharnait sur lui la prep
ils ont massacré la terre ils ont
lanfranc paix jusqu'à ce que parce que
plus d'une trentaine de jeunes frappent
dit patrice à terre très vite la police
arrive sur les lieux dans un état très
grave
l'homme âgé de 38 ans et transporté à
l'hôpital de caen il décédera dimanche
deux jeunes avaient de 17 et 19 ans ont
été interpellés deux jeunes déjà connus
des services de police pour la famille
de la victime
la justice est en partie responsable on
a un sentiment de révolte en vis-à-vis
de toute cette délinquance qui un qui
est en train de se créer dans toute la
france en général et on est totalement
et puissant même la justice baisse les
bras
les deux jeunes interpellés dimanche ont
été mises en examen pour coups ayant
entraîné la mort sans intention de la
donner
d'autres interpellations devraient
suivre dans les jours à venir
dans la sphère des viols en série de
collégiennes et d'écolière en région
parisienne le suspect interpellé
dimanche a été confondu par des indices
et des témoignages il aurait avoué
certains des faits il s'agit d'un
monsieur tout le monde selon un
enquêteur mais aussi d'un récidiviste il
avait déjà effectué de la prison d'où
une nouvelle fois les interrogations sur
l'absence de suivi des délinquants
sexuels
audrey goutard agnès gardait dans la
maison aux volets verts il n'y a plus
personne la femme du violeur et ses deux
enfants se sont réfugiés ailleurs pour
échapper au regard des autres le
tranquille père de famille était en fait
un violeur en série
on lui impute plus de 12 agression
d'adolescentes en cinq mois à paris
aujourd'hui il a été présenté à ses
victimes sept d'entre elles l'ont
formellement identifié au cours d'une
confrontation à la brigade des mineurs
personnes et parmi ces cinq personnes
la fille a reconnu son agresseur voilà
en garde à vue l'homme a reconnu les
faits son adn a été retrouvé sur deux
des viols c'est un multirécidiviste il a
déjà passé trois ans à la santé pour
huit agressions sexuelles sur mineures
commises entre 88 et 91
à sa sortie il a repris la vie de
famille entre le quartier de belleville
où il habitait à l'époque et son pays
d'origine la grèce aujourd'hui les
enquêteurs se demandent si depuis sa
sortie de prison en 94
il a récidivé le problème c'est que la
justice semble désarmée face aux
criminels en syrie je crois qu'il faut
en même temps que nous fassions nous
mêmes
je dirais jugé enquêteurs des efforts
d'organisation
ça c'est clair et en même temps que
lorsque nous faisons ces efforts
d'organisation
on nous donne les moyens de les mettre
en oeuvre de façon efficace plus de
moyens ce serait un fichier de
recoupement des viols et agressions en
série
il n'existe pas encore et pourtant
apparemment un autre violeur road en
région parisienne il a frappé plus de 20
fois en deux ans la délinquance dans les
transports maintenant le ministre de
l'intérieur daniel vaillant a inauguré
tout à l'heure le poste de commandement
unique de la police des transports ici
près de la gare du nord à paris
il est relié en permanence à l'ensemble
des forces présentes sur le terrain et
bien sûr aux caméras de
vidéosurveillance yann fronty eric de
l'agneau au contraire les trains du
trafic la police teste son nouveau
dispositif ici ces hommes ont l'oeil sur
tout le réseau ile de france avec ses
cartes ces caméras
les outils sont tout neufs plus efficace
un étage plus bas système équivalent
pour la sncf cette fois
pour passer quatre heures mais sur le
terrain ses policiers de la brigade des
chemins de fer reste en contact
permanent avec leur pc en plus de trois
heures de patrouille c'est la première
vraie infractions ces jeunes était en
train de fumer un joint que du cannabis
cette fois le contrôle se passe bien
dans le calme les noms sont transmis
officiers 14 978 prénom et les joints
écrasé la routine pour cette équipe
c'est là la queue du train donc tous les
gens qui veulent fumer dans les prince
mais tant que je ferai donc à une fois
sur deux une faction 30 à peu près sûr
que directeur de fumer une cigarette
voire plus grâce au nouveau dispositif
ces policiers espèrent gagner en
rapidité
demain ils pourront peut-être intervenir
à temps comme dans cette gare totalement
bombe et vandalisé il y a quelques jours
ils sont arrivés trop tard et ils n'ont
rien pu faire sinon constater les dégâts
l'actualité à l'étranger d'abord la
situation au proche orient avec cet
attentat en galilée au nord d'israël
près de la frontière libanaise attaques
armées contre plusieurs véhicules sept
israéliens dont cinq civils ont été tués
ainsi que trois des assaillants
un homme est en fuite il est activement
recherché pas de revendication pour
l'instant
israël qui a fait un geste hier en
desserrant l'étau autour de yasser
arafat
mais les optimistes ont dû déchanter
l'opération menée par l'armée à gaza et
ramallah ces dernières 24 heures et sans
précédent même si on s'habitue désormais
entre guillemets aux bilans les plus
lourds cette journée restera dans les
mémoires 39 morts côté palestinien
charles enderlin sur place el bireh un
faubourg à l'est de ramallah
les rues sont désertes le quartier sous
couvre feu
ici les soldats ont fait signe de ne pas
s'approcher l'opération principale se
déroule quelques kilomètres plus loin
aux abords du camp de réfugiés à la
marie toutes les voies d'accès sont
coupés haut parleurs diffusent un
message dernier appelle tous les hommes
âgés de 16 à 40 ans avec ou sans armes
doivent se rendre dans la cour de
l'école
depuis les rues avoisinantes des
combattants tirs à la kalachnikov sur
les chars qui ripostent les israéliens
ne sont pas arrivés jusqu'à la place
centrale de ramallah des hommes armés
les attendaient
ici ce matin un palestinien accusé de
collaboration avec israël a été exécuté
pendu ou senna cher numéro deux du patar
en cisjordanie promet que six militants
ont résisté jusqu'à jeu si la dernière
goutte de sang le bureau de rabat est à
sa 100 m miguel moratinos l'émissaire
européen au proche-orient arrive comme
de réfugiés hier elle peut pas accepter
cette occupation continue et je viens
arafat pourra-t-il imposer un cessez le
feu
rien n'est moins sûr ces forces de
police sont en pleine débandade et il
sait que ce matin à gaza au puits de
vengeance et non aux négociations et qui
serait une foule immense a participé aux
obsèques de 17 palestiniens tués hier
charles enderlin bonsoir quelques
explications peut être fière la tendance
on l'a dit était plutôt à l'apaisement
comment s'y retrouver
eh bien écoutez la détente hier était
tout virtuel
ariel sharon et les chefs de son armée
ont répété qu'ils allaient poursuivre
leurs opérations contre ce qu'ils
appellent les nids de terroristes
ils sont persuadés qu'à long terme leur
politique sera payante
l'autorité palestinienne elle estime
qu'elle a été virtuellement pratiquement
détruite par les raids israéliens sa
police de fait n'existe plus et surtout
après chaque raid il y a presque
systématiquement des représailles de la
part des organisations armées alors
yasser arafat est persuadé que dans les
tout prochains jours on va assister au
sérieux suivant avant l'arrivée au
proche-orient du médiateur américain
anthony zinni les chars vont se retirer
de ramallah à ce moment là il y aura des
attentats israélien qu'il arafat ne
pourra pas empêcher
et une fois de plus il sera accusé de ne
pas lutter contre le terrorisme
monsieur il n'y a décidément beaucoup
beaucoup de pain sur la planche
attentat contre israël oui merci charles
images de new york où les commémorations
du 11-septembre se sont achevées hier
avec l'apparition de ces deux tours de
lumière on va les découvrir si tout va
bien à la place des deux bâtiments du
world trade center
c'est la fille d'un policier mort dans
les attentats qui a appuyé sur le bouton
44 projecteurs géant de chaque côté les
faisceaux sont visibles à 30 kilomètres
à la ronde
ils s'illumineront tous les soirs
pendant un mois au zimbabwe le début du
dépouillement d'un scrutin contesté de
nombreux électeurs ont effet violemment
expulsés des bureaux parfois à coups de
carabine sans avoir pu voter et la
communauté internationale ne prend plus
de gants
le président robert mugabe a semble-t-il
volé les élections un dicton par exemple
ce soir à londres
au delà il ya la situation d'un pays qui
s'enfonce quelques points de repères on
s'arrête un moment pour comprendre le
zimbabwe autrefois appelée rhodésie est
indépendant depuis 1981 pays presque
aussi grand que la france peuplé de 12
millions d'habitants dont 1 1% à peine
de blanc qui possède les trois quarts
des terres cultivées alors pour
s'attirer les grâces des électeurs
nougat b a lancé une réforme agraire
sans concertation par la violence et la
terreur par l'occupation des terres
résultat la production est en chute
libre le pays autrefois exportateur
connaît désormais la fin envoyés
spéciaux eric monier bruno girodon
d'interminables files d'attentes pour
tenter d'acheter quelques kilos de maïs
ou de sucre scènes de la vie quotidienne
à harare la pénurie alimentaire
inimaginable il ya seulement deux ans
dans ce pays longtemps considéré comme
le grenier de l'afrique australe
pourquoi cette situation le gouvernement
incriminent la sécheresse mais ce sont
dans ces fermes industrielles qu'il faut
chercher la réponse
ces immenses exploitations restée aux
mains des blancs après l'indépendance
mais que le gouvernement de robert
mugabe s'est mise en tête de démanteler
au nom d'une plus juste répartition des
terres roj
posséder plus de mille hectares de
céréales sa ferme est désormais occupée
par des militants pro mugabe
elle ne produit presque plus rien voyez
il ya plus de récolte qui a plus rien
plus rien à faire pour que cette ferme
redevienne compétitive
il doit mettre des fermiers compétents
ici c'est pas moi quelqu'un d'autre qui
connaissaient mais c'est évidemment chez
les plus pauvres que la crise fait le
plus de dégâts pour survivre ephraim et
sa famille ne compte plus que sur
l'argent envoyés de l'étranger par des
parents et sur la vente au marché
parallèle de quelques légumes qu'ils
cultivent dans son jardin mais quant à
fo on ne peut pas se payer un minimum le
même se faire engueuler chaude aussi
accrocheur
comment vous expliquez cela croyait
sous-nombre sais pas mais je crois
qu'elle la corruption dans ce
gouvernement mais des gens se servent de
nos ressources utilisées notre argent
celui du contribuable
on croit que c'est ça le problème
ephraïm le chômeur et roye l'ancien
fermier ont tous deux voté pour
l'opposition mais tous deux avaient
aussi redouter que robert mugabe ne
parvienne à se maintenir au pouvoir par
la fraude électorale en afrique du nord
des nouvelles du jeune roi marocain
mohamed 6 il annonce officiellement son
mariage avec sa fiancée salma bennani ce
sera le 21
marcel à 24 ans elle est diplômée en
informatique la roumanie maintenant et
les inquiétudes françaises devant le
nombre croissant d'enfants roumains
isolés en france la semaine dernière un
accord a été conclu entre paris et
bucarest
cela dit plus généralement l'immigration
des roumains est aussi un sujet
d'attention depuis le 1er janvier ils
n'ont plus besoin de visa pour entrer
dans l'espace schengen c'est aux
autorités roumaines d'effectuer les
contrôles de toute évidence elles sont
débordés bucarest paris celle en quête
de cette édition elle est signée
dorothée cochard et paul quotidienne
dans les kiosques de bucarest
le rêve européen fait vendre
au bout de la pince à linge on accroche
un hebdomadaire vient de sortir son
titre le travail à l'étranger où le
guide pratique et honnête pour les
audacieux avec tous ces gens qui ont
besoin de partir à l'étranger
nos futures y aura plus personne au
prochain chan sont plusieurs dizaines de
bus partent chaque semaine de bucarest
destination la france l'italie ou
l'espagne pour le tourisme surprise pour
le travail parfois les autorités
roumaines d'elle même cherche à empêcher
l'église de travailleurs clandestins
elles ont établi des règles strictes
chaque voyageur doit fournir en plus de
ces papiers 100 euros par jour ou à
défaut une invitation pour l'un comme
pour l'autre les fraudes sont facile il
suffit d'ouvrir les journaux et devenir
le petit anneau certains propose
d'avancer l'argent pour une petite
commission
d'autres vont jusqu'à vendre de vraies
fausses invitations
nous avons rappelé je voulais savoir si
vous pouvez nous procurer une invitation
légaliser pour la france et si possible
très vite je vous propose une invitation
en provenance d'italie parce que c'est à
la frontière avec l'autriche
et là il n'y a plus de problème les
autrichiens vous laisse passer les
diatement si l'invitation vient d'italie
toujours plus tard après lui avoir
transmis une photocopie de passeport aux
mains nous rencontrons l'homme dans sa
voiture rien recevoir le document
d'italie et nous fournit ce document
dûment estampillés c'est une invitation
dans une université
là vous voyez il assume toutes leurs
responsabilités pour votre séjour
supposé en italie et ça c'est quoi c'est
un tampon italien oui oui ça c'est le
tampon de la mairie
nous avons alors pris le bus 14 heures
de trajet nous voulions voir si ce
document permettait bien à notre
cameraman romain de franchir la
frontière avec la hongrie les policiers
roumains monte dans le bus il vérifie la
validité des passeports que les
passagers possède bien les 100 euros par
jour ou à défaut ces fameuses invitation
nous présentons la montre
le pathos
à étrave de terrain
l'habitation est en bonne et due forme
nous franchissons la frontière et
travers son art
la police roumaine prétend que les
fraudes sont rares mais en même temps
elle s'avoue impuissante devant de tels
trafics
ce n'était pas pour ça c'est clairement
de problèmes de la france ni pour ce qui
est des documents ont peut-être ailleurs
s'ils sont héros reste à dakar mais
s'ils sont valables on ne peut rien
faire et nous porter un patch absous
limites
depuis le début de l'année 35 mille
personnes ont été refoulées par les
policiers roumains coup de 915 millions
passée braise ou faux touristes
la mort de l'un des économistes les plus
célèbres du monde james tobin 84 ans
prix nobel si son nom ne vous dit rien
vous connaissez au moins sans doute
l'idée à laquelle il a donné son nom la
taxe tobin taxer les flux financiers
internationaux pour réduire la
spéculation proposition désormais au
centre du combat anti mondialisation
entre guillemets son auteur lui acquis
au libéralisme avait pris ses distances
nathalie moisan le professeur et prix
nobel d'économie américain james tobin
serait sans doute resté inconnu du grand
public
s'il n'était devenu récemment l'emblème
des anti mondialisation
en 1971 il propose de taxer les échanges
monétaires internationaux l'objectif
freiner la spéculation financière
une idée reprise par l'association
attaqué dans ces slogans sous le nom de
taxe tobin et les anti mondialisation
d'aller plus loin
la taxe permettrait de financer l'aide
aux pays du tiers-monde
seul hic tobin avait lui même dénoncé
cette récupération ce keynésien social
démocrate et ancien conseiller de
kennedy se disait partisan du
libre-échange
contrairement à ses supporters disait je
suis toujours pour la taxe tobin il
ajouté ils n'y croyaient pas politique
bon mais nous sommes là justement pour
pour lutter pour politiquement elle
passe donc la taxe tobin elle reste
d'actualité
la taxe tobin a déjà fait du chemin du
moins sur le principe en décembre
l'assemblée nationale française la même
voté mais à condition que tous les pays
de l'union européenne la docte aussi on
n'y est pas encore
économie toujours manifestation de
quelques dizaines d'emplois jeunes
devant le ministère de l'économie et des
finances à bercy
ils demandent une pérennisation de leur
situation
les emplois jeunes c'était une des
mesures phares de la législature jospin
ils sont actuellement en france au
nombre de 225000 pour près de la moitié
d'entre eux le contrat s'achève dans les
mois qui viennent souvent il débouchera
sur un emploi stable
parfois non alors quel bilan tire les
intéressés nous avons suivi les parcours
de grégoire et d'eric il avait obtenu un
emploi jeune
en 98 où en sont ils aujourd'hui
reportage génicart aussi benoît jourdain
c'était il ya trois ans derrière ses
jumelles grégoire nous disait sa passion
pour les oiseaux son bonheur de
travailler dans la réserve naturelle du
marais du vigueirat avec un contrat
emploi jeune
un aboutissement je suis arrivé ici en
première fois il ya en 92 et c'est en
tant que bénévole éric emplois-jeunes
lui aussi s'occuper des visites et de la
formation des guides un compromis idéal
entre sa formation de vendeur et son
amour de la nature
je joue en fait sur ces deux sur ces
deux axes la fois avoir un boulot on
pourrait rêver mieux en fait on pourrait
pas rêver mieux
ça peut être aussi bien un produit pour
l'investisseur aussi aujourd'hui les
choses ont bien changé la passion des
oiseaux est réservé aux loisirs
eric a quitté il ya un an son emploi
jeune fatiguée de travailler les
week-ends pour le smic il s'est lancé
dans le monde plus terre à terre de
l'immobilier c'est vrai j'ai envie de
passer à autre chose
j'ai envie de me poser sur arles j'ai
envie de points à gagner ma vie
correctement
gregor de son côté parcours toujours le
marais observe les oiseaux il a choisi
par passion d'aller jusqu'au terme de
son contrat emploi jeune en juin 2003
les avantages dont déjà c'est d'avoir du
boulot ça permet aussi d'avoir un
contrat de 2 5 ans donc de pouvoir
avoir cinq années pour faire ses preuves
acquérir vraiment une expérience
grégoire gagne le smic mais l'année
prochaine après onze ans passés au
marais entre bénévolat et emplois jeunes
il devrait être définitivement embauché
la passion finira par payer
économie encore avec ces chiffres de
l'insee les prélèvements obligatoires
ont représenté en 2001 44 9% du pib le
produit intérieur brut
c'est un peu moins qu'en l'an 2000 50
par dont 45,1 mais ce chiffre place la
france dans les premiers en europe pour
les prélèvements et à propos de dépenses
publiques questions sur la sécurité
routière le magazine autoplus dénonce un
gaspillage dans la gestion des campagnes
d'information vincent fourcade jean-paul
chos était 2001 la dernière campagne
d'information de la sécurité routière
avertir les automobilistes des dangers
de la route c'est la mission de cet
organisme public la sécurité routière
aura l'an dernier dépensé quelque 12
millions d'euros pour promouvoir ses
messages de prudence
mais pour le magazine auto plus
l'addition aurait pu être beaucoup moins
lourde si la sécurité routière n'avait
pas tendance à jeter l'argent public par
les fenêtres
malheureusement comme on l'a découvert
ils sous traitent tout alla pour des
montants faramineux
partez du principe qu'à 10 à 15 millions
de francs qui partent certainement
chaque année en fumée
et l'hebdomadaire d'égrainer les
exemples de dépenses injustifiées
ces trois affiches tout d'abord réalisé
par une agence privée alors que la
sécurité routière salary à plein temps
un photographe 15000 euros le cliché
pour une campagne qui ne verra jamais le
jour
de plus alors que l'organisme public
bénéficient d'un service de
communication fort de 20 personnes ils
préfèrent déléguer au prix fort une
bonne partie de son travail à une
société extérieure ou mensuelle près de
cent vingt mille euros
indignation de la sécurité routière qui
ne conçoit pas que l'hôtel sommes
puissent être engagées à la légère le
souci de chaque personne qui travaille à
la sécurité routière c'est de sauver des
vies c'est d'éviter des blessures graves
d'éviter des drames et croyez bien que
tous on se dit qu'il faut être rigoureux
l'an dernier le budget de la sécurité
routière a été augmenté d'un tiers le
nombre d'accidents lui n'a pas reculé
plus de 7600 morts et près de 160 mille
blessés en 2000 à grenoble c'est le
centre hospitalier qui est en accusation
suite à la mort d'un bébé d'un an la
petite deborah souffrait d'une gastro
entérite ses parents se sont présentés
plusieurs fois aux urgences hospitalisés
trop tard elle est morte de
déshydratation virginie pichet jean
claude martin un an après la douleur est
toujours là avec elle
toujours le même sentiment d'injustice
et de révolte la façon qu'elle est parti
donc en rien une gastro entérite qui a
coûté la vie à leur petite fille
aujourd'hui le rapport d expertise qui
vient d'être rendue note qu'une
accumulation d'erreurs est à l'origine
du drame
la plus lourde concerne le délai de
prise en charge en état de
déshydratation
la petite fille a pourtant attendu
cinquante minutes avant que l'équipe des
urgences temps de lui poser une
perfusion 50 minutes c'était 42,3 qui si
elle était soignée 15 mai aps serré
encore à l'hôpital de son côté ne
conteste pas le retard mais invoque un
contexte exceptionnel en guise de
circonstances atténuantes
la pauvre deborah attendu à certaines de
minutes parce que notre enfant était lui
même arrivé avant était en danger de
mort dans ces conditions je vois mal
comment on pourrait reprocher une faute
à l'hôpital qui a fait tout ce qui était
en son pouvoir
aix cuisine acceptable pour les parents
de deborah une expertise leur a apporté
un début d'espoir celui que soit
reconnue ce qui restera pour eux une
terrible négligence qu'ils ne veulent
jamais voir se reproduire sentait
toujours avec les fabricants de tabac
une nouvelle fois sur la sellette et
plus particulièrement le géant américain
philip morris
selon une étude publiée dans une revue
britannique la firme aurait vendu
pendant 40 ans des cigarettes présentant
des filtres défectueux en toute
connaissance de cause a pas de certitude
pour l'instant seulement des
présomptions laetitia phuc sophie rozier
des années que ce chercheur américain
john poli se bat contre philip morris
aujourd'hui après avoir passé au peigne
fin des milliers de documents
appartenant aux fabricants il accuse les
filtres du cigarettier sont défectueux
depuis 40 ans et philip morris le savez
le fumeur en plus d'inhaler les 40
composants toxiques habituel aspire des
fibres d'acétate de cellulose
ce n'est pas là ses tables de cellulose
lui-même c'est la forme sous laquelle il
est puisque ce sont des petits filaments
qui vont hériter la branche et en
irritant la branche vont multiplier
favoriser l'action cancérigène de toutes
les goudrons de son côté philip morris
se fait discret et nie tout risque pour
la santé
le fabricant s'appuie sur des études
qu'il a lui même commandé selon elle
inspirée fibré particules ne va pas les
risques de cancer aux etats unis le
débat est ouvert depuis plus de sept ans
pourtant les autorités sanitaires n'ont
encore pris aucune mesure
la mort du cardinal louis marie billets
archevêque de lyon et ancien président
de la conférence des évêques de france
il avait démissionné de ce dernier poste
pour se soigner
après avoir révélé qu'il était atteint
d'un cancer très nombreux hommages ce
soir c'est notamment sous sa
responsabilité que les évêques avaient
fait acte de repentance pour les
silences de l'église sous l'occupation
il avait également été au coeur du
succès des jmj les journées mondiales de
la jeunesse en août 97
louis-marie vie y avait 64 ans la
campagne présidentielle premier grand
meeting de jacques chirac à marseille ce
soir 8000 personnes rassemblées pour
l'écouter
le président de la république a réitéré
ses critiques contre je cite la logique
socialiste sur place véronique
saint-aulaye philippe tueur fou la salle
est surchauffée plein à craquer
près de 7000 supporters hurle leur
enthousiasme sur la musique des chariots
de feu jacques chirac ce soir berne
avait à ses côtés a retrouvé les siens
pour ce premier meeting
rien n'a été laissé au hasard c'est
l'ambiance qui compte il ya les proches
au premier rang pour l'image de l'équipe
soudée et la salle aux trois cas rpr qui
fait un triomphe à son candidat
un candidat comme pour répondre à lionel
jospin n'apparaît ni vieilli usé mais
porté au contraire par l'élan populaire
avant toi un homme de terrain c'est un
humaniste
aujourd'hui je crois qu'on a besoin
d'humanisme habilité la sécurité à
travers ce jacques chirac espère enfin
engager le dialogue en direct avec les
français
alors le candidat dénonce la france qui
sous les socialistes auraient selon lui
marqué le pas il dénonce le déclin
économique et l'insécurité
nous en sommes là parce que s'est
développée en france une logique
socialiste
le mot
le mot socialiste semble-t-il dérange et
l'on veut faire du socialisme sans le
dire pourtant pourtant l'idéologie
socialiste est bien là al'inverse
jacques chirac propose plus
d'assouplissement dans le dialogue
social et l'application des 35 heures
plus d'autorité aussi à tous les niveaux
de la société séduction la campagne
semble donc bien relancé mais il reste à
jacques chirac désormais à se poser en
rassembleur comme celui qui est capable
d'apporter aux français un projet
nouveau les polémiques et les échanges
de coups avec lionel jospin ont donc été
mis en sourdine pour le moment au moins
lionel jospin lui-même ses gardes et d'y
revenir aujourd'hui
mais après ces mots sur l'âge du
président et à l'occasion d'un petit
problème de lunettes
il ne s'est pas privé de ce clin d'oeil
écoutez il porte la parole du candidat
que je suis dans les 777
circonscriptions où ils seront candidats
1 qu'est ce que j'ai dit faites-en dans
500 577
non c'est vrai en plus surtout en bas de
page un peu de mal à la comédie donc
enfin bon je vais pas faire de remarques
1 sur ce sujet donc donc dans les 577
circonscriptions de notre pays voit la
conférence de presse tout à l'heure à
son atelier de campagne jean marie le
pen lui était à toulouse hier soir et
pour lui aussi c'était son premier grand
meeting informations données par le
président du front national
il me manque 80 signatures de parrainage
pour me présenter à l'élection dit il
alain madelin présenter lui son
programme économique à paris mesure
phare la retenue à la source de l'impôt
sur le revenu qui le comporterait
puisque trois tranches avec un taux
maximum à 33%
alain madelin qui défend par ailleurs un
revenu familial garantie et souhaite une
profonde réforme de l'état
si jacques chirac et lionel jospin sont
toujours donnés largement favoris la
bataille pour la 3e place semble elle de
plus en plus ouverte
les derniers sondages marquent un recul
de jean pierre chevènement le troisième
homme pourrait être une femme arlette
laguiller accrédités même de 9% des
intentions de vote par deux instituts
arlette laguiller cinquième campagne
emilie lançons frédéric bonne ces
temps-ci arlette laguiller ne fait que
passer dans son hlm aux lilas juste le
temps de refaire sa valise et de
reprendre la route
à force de sillonner la france arlette
et à 9% dans les sondages elle dépasse
même le parti communiste et pensent
savoir pourquoi sa participation au
gouvernement
qui lui faire cautionner des mesures
anti-ouvrières qui lui fait cautionner
le fait que lionel jospin ne s'élève pas
contre les plans de licenciements qui
ont lieu dans tout le pays que tout cela
sûrement fait que certains électeurs
pensent qu'après tout c'est quoi être en
dix robes et russe est plus utile de
voter pour moi faudra compter que les
élections ça se sache et tout a changé
dans le monde du travail
enfin on est d'accord la candidate de
lutte ouvrière espère toujours la
révolution mais en attendant elle
prépare les élections alors elle va
chercher les voix là où elles sont ici
devant une usine danone promise à la
fermeture
oui les travailleurs ou en face d'eux
des gens qui ont des coffres forts à la
place du coeur et je serai toujours avec
vous et eux sont toujours aussi fan
disons que ya très longtemps encore
aller
en train de se battre pour les ouvriers
pour les camarades et tous et il faudra
quelques appâts sont ouverts le nom du
rectum c'est bien elle est allée
toujours tenace elle est restée simple
et humble bravo depuis 30 ans arlette
laguiller et la voix et le visage de
lutte ouvrière sa première élection
présidentielle remonte à 74 je suis une
femme
et j'ose me présenter comme candidate à
la présidence de cette république
d'hommes depuis le discours et les
styles n'ont pas changé ou presque
mais avec la grille est devenue une
vedette arlette laguiller qui distancent
désormais robert hue le candidat du pcf
pour se relancer à présenter aujourd'hui
quatre affiches de sa campagne réalisée
avec l'aide de l'écrivain et animateur
et ex publicitaire branché frédéric
beigbeder thème central et dont la
gauche à rester la gauche éducation
controverse autour des méthodes d'une
institutrice de saint maur dans le val
de marne elle est accusée d'avoir abusé
de punition humiliante envers ses élèves
de six ans exemple en cas de bavardages
excessif
elle leur fermer la bouche à l'aide
d'une pince à linge reportage diego
garcia à la location
hors des murs de l'école les langues
commencent à se délier contesté par
certains parents la méthode d'éducation
d'une institutrice exemple lorsqu'il
s'agit de punir l'enseignante utilise
une pince à linge pour fermer la bouche
des enfants trauma var et ce n'est pas
qui c'est mon bras dans la cour et on
avait demandé donc j'écrive pas quoi et
puis elle a dit non non non pas question
il va écrire et tous et nous en fait
j'avais super mal je ne veux pas écrire
et tout côté mauvaises élèves et 20 il
faisait des bêtises donner des fessées
qu'est ce que tu pourrais du apple alors
pour résumer ou en fait quelques pas des
supers méthode mais qu'on apprend
bientôt entre les parents qui sont pour
et ceux qui sont contre
le débat est ouvert peut-être qu'il y a
eu des problèmes des caractères de
mésententes et je ne sais pas moi tout
ce que je peux dire je ne peux pas
témoigner contre parce que moi ça a été
au contraire un bien pour mon fils tout
cela n'est qu'un jeu pour l'institutrice
mise en cause ce que n'accepte pas
certains parents l'oea a été à l'école
très stressée avec le système de la
passe à linge avec le système des cayes
est jeté par terre
donc moi la question que je me pose
aujourd'hui en fait la question je me
pose aujourd'hui c'est savoir est ce que
est ce que nous en tant qu'adulte on
aura accepté d'avoir une pince à linge
de corps de sanctions administratives
après un mois de congé maladie
l'enseignante a repris ses cours l'afer
a été rapportée à l'inspection
académique de créteil qui n'a pas encore
tranché
à propos d'éducation et de
responsabilités la conversion d'un
rappeur alix mathurin alias kery james
il est ce soir à l'olympia à paris
d'ordinaire le rap c'est surtout la
contestation voire l'appel à la révolte
kery james lui a brusquement changé de
cap il prône désormais la morale eh oui
si mathias hillion christian galley kery
james sort d'un long silence
un jour d'été 99 l'un de ses proches est
assassiné le rappeur stoppe net sa
carrière fini les textes virulents fini
l'équipe violent et sous des quartiers
là où nous nous apprêtons à bitche
conséquence trois ans plus tard il
revient avec un album apaisé et réussi
l'exploit de réunir tous les grands noms
du rap français autour d'une chanson en
forme de mise en garde très ferme
cette fois ci remet en cause lundi du
dieu plutôt que
plutôt que le système est en disant je
suis pas là pour voir dire ce qu'ils
veulent entendre c'est une manière de
dire que je fais ce que je veux voir way
et que je ne me sens pas désigné d'un
personnage quelconque sur celle nature
vêtements de marque pas de chaînes en or
ou kery james dénonce le culte des
drogues douces de l'argent et des plus
faciles converti à l'islam il assume sa
nouvelle image de rappeur moral j'aime
bien souligner qu'on arrivait une époque
tellement étonnant qu'aujourd'hui il
deviendrait soi-disant honte d'avoir de
la morale la rendit aux intel c'est un
moraliste et soi disant on devrait avoir
en contrôlant la morale c'est quelque
chose c'est quelque chose de bio donc
que les gens considèrent que je sois la
conscience morale du nord absents ça ne
me dérange pas du tout
personne pas au rap de rue 20 pouces des
gens comme ça mais pas des gens du
disque d'or depuis peu kery james a
repris le micro pour faire entendre sa
différence ce soir donc à l'olympia la
mode suit des défilés automne hiver 2002
2003 avec peut-être la collection la
plus attendue celle d'yves saint laurent
le maître est parti le successeur tom
ford joue la continuité du noir toujours
du noir est une ode à la féminité
estelle colin david fossard les ormes
est seul maître à bord d'une des crises
les plus mythiques du monde tom ford
choisi de revisiter le xviiie siècle
celui des libertines sulfureuse dans des
bustiers courts ces petits génies départ
benussi légère dévergondée dans les
dentelles indécente dans des jupes
droites de velours jantes rasé
collection aux faussaires de couture
même plus l'homme ne se dit pas encore
prêt à occuper le siège laissé vide par
le départ d'yves saint laurent
non pas tellement non pour l'instant
absolument pas bien sûr il y avait ce
sentiment dans cette collection yves
saint laurent est à l'origine une maison
de haute couture c'est la culture de la
maison
ce que je voulais faire c'était des
vêtements luxueux mais tout de même du
prêt-à-porter lui tom ford et le groupe
gucci qui appartient désormais la griffe
yves saint laurent pourrait bien décider
un jour de relancer la haute couture
puisqu'ils ont acquis pour 70 millions
de dollars la propriété intellectuelle
de la marque
en attendant on gardera en mémoire cette
vision de ce prêt à porter ses coutures
fin de cette édition à suivre la météo
nathalie rihouet 1h dernier journal eve
mettait demain dès 6h30 télématin dans
les 4 vérités françoise laborde recevra
corinne lepage
on se quitte avec ces images d'un chiot
très remarquée dans cette couv et en
corée du sud
il est vert sans doute à cause d'un
problème d'oxygène à la naissance à
demain